I have a really sort of boneheaded clip
to play for you today from a Republican
senator from Florida Rick Scott and the
clip is interesting but really it's
going to serve as a kind of jumping-off
point for us to talk about really some
of the basics of how the American
economy is organized and how it is
really based on the type of relationship
that we have with China and so the point
of this is for us to better understand
why Donald Trump's critique of the
us-china trade relationship is so wrong
and so misguided and you really can't
understand that unless you understand
some of what we're going to talk about
here so as many of you know you've
probably heard Trump say and it's true
the United States imports a ton of stuff
from China this includes raw materials
this includes finished electronic
products and other products and we don't
export as much to China as we import
from China meaning we have a trade
deficit with China the obvious reasons
why this is the situation include labor
is cheaper in China the weaker
regulatory environment in China also
makes it financially advantageous to do
this that's all true but there's really
a lot more to this that we have to
understand so to set the conversation
here's Florida senator Rick Scott he's a
Republican of course saying nobody in
the united states should be buying stuff
from communist China let's look at what
he had to say I believe this was
yesterday or the day before on the floor
of the Senate which prohibits the u.s.
government from purchasing drones
manufactured in countries identified as
national security threats like Iran and
China we know Commons China steals their
technology and intellectual parklet
property yet the US government continues
to buy critical technology like drones
with American tax dollars from Chinese
companies backed by their government no
one in America should buy products made
in communist China especially not the US
government we cannot continue this
practice and my American security drone
act is a common-sense solution to end
this threat to our national security so
what these
and to be honest many Democrats get this
wrong as well what is being missed about
the China trade conversations so often
is that our trade deficit with China and
China holding so much American debt as
they do through bonds this is not a bug
in the system we might not like it but
it's a feature of how this the system is
designed and and I'll explain to you
what that means
collectively the United States decided
implicitly the United States decided
decades ago that we value cheap products
from China more than we value domestic
production we don't want to pay more for
stuff that's made in the United States
when I say we you might be ok with it
but as a country in organizing our
economy our leaders have decided we want
the cheap stuff from China so our entire
economy is based around specialization
and this includes exporting services
like we increasingly do to China but
importing products products that have
been made in China because the demand
for these products is so high and many
of these products would not be
affordable to everyday Americans if they
were manufactured in the United States
now that's because of a whole other set
of problems but if we're going to talk
about the us-china trade relationship we
have to sort of set this basic
understanding so naturally this means
we're going to import more stuff from
China then we're going to export and
that's where you get a trade deficit
that's the trade deficit Trump refers to
and many Republicans refer to now when
you hear the word deficit it sounds bad
it's meant to sound bad because we think
Oh deficits bad surplus is good if you
think about your household economy your
household budget you want to be running
a surplus you want to have something
left over at the end of the month rather
than than to be deficit spending
charging stuff at the end of the month
with the trade relationship it's not
deficit bad surplus good necessarily we
run a trade deficit by design because of
how we've organized the economy to
depend on that cheap stuff from China so
everybody in the US can afford more
stuff instead of less stuff and part of
what keeps China competitive in the
context is that they set the value of
their currency relative to the dollar
using what's called a modified fixed
exchange rate which basically means if
the dollar loses value China will start
buying dollars through bonds this is how
China ends up holding so much of our
debt because they want to keep that
exchange rate between the dollar and the
yuan roughly the same now over the last
few years China has reduced the degree
to which they do this but part of why
China is buying so many bonds and
holding so much of our debt is because
of this trade relationship that we
decided we wanted in order to keep the
flow of cheap Chinese stuff coming to
the United States now I think it's a
good moment to mention you here the
right always go crazy China owns us
china owns our debt Japan actually holds
more of our debt than China but for
political reasons you don't really hear
much about that Japan's just not
considered a threat in the same way that
China is because their economy is a
different type of economy but the point
here is we as a country we as an economy
could decide we don't want to import
stuff from China anymore we don't like
the political idea of importing stuff
from China we don't like the economic
idea as Rick Scott said let's stop
buying from Communist China we could do
that if we wanted but you have to
understand that specialization and trade
including with China in total have
created more jobs in the United States
than have been destroyed due to
outsourcing we've given tens of millions
of Americans access to products which we
now take for granted so I'm not
defending it what I'm saying is if we
want to have the conversation of no
longer having a trade deficit with China
of no longer buying stuff from Communist
China as Rick Scott says we can do that
it would have massive consequences here
in the United States things would get
more expensive a lot of people would
lose jobs but we might decide that in
the long run it's worth it but if we're
going to have this conversation we have
to have the full conversation because we
have the
Phantasy conversation where Trump says
get rid of the trade deficit Rick Scott
says don't buy stuff from Communist
China and people end up coming away with
this idea that we could just stop buying
from China manufactured domestically and
the economy would be otherwise
unaffected other than we've brought jobs
home or whatever the case may be that's
not the reality so I'm not saying what
would be right or wrong what I'm
pointing out is we have decades of
economic policy built upon the
foundation of we value the flow of cheap
goods from China more than we value a
lot of other things that we could value
in the economy don't allow Republicans
like Rick Scott and Trump and even some
Democrats who don't really understand
this don't let them oversimplify this
into stupidity with let's just end the
trade deficit type of stuff because we
have decades of implicit and explicit
decisions built upon we want to keep the
free I'm sorry we want to keep the cheap
stuff coming from China if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blink it's linked
Isleta consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash
Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video